here's alcitus escobar
well there's another line drive soft
enough
that it drops and strong enough to get
over
chisholm so then that's two on nobody
out and the table is set
so two out the base is loaded it'll be
up to cave ruiz
how about that
fought it off it's gonna drive in a
couple
thomas comes around
soto behind him
and kate ruiz collects rbi's number
seven and eight and his sixth and
seventh isn't that two nothing
muscles it out there so broken bat
single wants soto with a great lead
great secondary lead so no throw at home
worth repeating the nats are 47 and 29
when they score first all of a sudden
ruiz is hot
and here's lane thomas second time
around
thomas hits it well out to center de la
cruz tearing back see
you
later
this leadoff's man's power to center
field is amazing three to nothing mats
playing thomas with his sixth home run
stay in your lane and his lane is
straight away center field now elaine
thomas continues to impress and impress
the cleanup hit over the marlins
lewis brinson
gets under one high to left
the ballpark will hold it and so will
josh bell
that took forever to come down
and josh was waiting and waiting to time
his jump oh he's seven foot eight so he
made the play
but he was fired up about it that was
the best part he was originally an
outfielder the pirates moved into first
but watch the reaction from josh open up
your hips square up get some air bring
it back
and then he's all excited as he throws
the bullet did he rob one
he did pulled it back there's jazz top
of the order for the marlins here in the
third two balls and no strikes on jazz
here it comes from fetty
and jazz with a drive out to right
oh boy second deck for jazz a long home
run
[Music]
second time through pal second time i'm
just kidding
well his offense needs to wake up just a
bit against fetty he has had some kind
of success but chad says huh not this
time jazz does a nice job staying on the
back side pulling the hands through
415 feet into the upper deck now partner
when he finds it it is pretty to watch
i would uh categorize that as majestic
ground ball and that one gets through
escobar and into center field
de la cruz is on his way to second and
he'll get there tying run at the plate
one ball and no strikes on sanchez de la
cruz on at second here it comes
and now sanchez unloads this one to
right center field it's deep it's gone
and it's tied
now the big guy continues to come up
with big swings for the marlins he has
just tied this ball game up
same pitch maybe a little bit higher in
the strike zone
he got every bit of that hanging
curveball
rosado shook off his catcher on the
first pitch
now throws a fastball it's up and in
ball four
great swing the other way ball slicing
away from sanchez it'll bounce up and
hit the rail juan can slow up at third
that's out of play that upper rail there
so josh bell with the ground rule double
second and third nobody out on a
fantastic swing the other way ruiz
turning around about left-handed now the
pitch on the way
jammed him ground ball pulled fair
inside the first base back down the line
soto scores from third bell around 30
he's coming home the throw will go to
second base two runs batted in he's
driven in four in the game and the
nationals are back in front here in the
fifth inning it's washington five in
miami three
on a pitch up and away it's the other
way by garcia
now coming around third is ruiz
heading for third and sliding in
is kibum
and the nets are moving the line all
over the place a couple of bags at a
time
top of the order here is jazz
a payoff pitch from feddy
and jazz hits one
way out toward right center he does it
again
another solo home run for jazz chisholm
jr and the marlins pull within two
another look at the home run first
multi-homer game of his career remember
the big swing and miss on the 2-1 pitch
that was a curveball that
teddy went in on i thought it would work
a second time it did not
thomas looking to add to the nationals
lead
that's a wild pitch
keep boom coming home
the call is safe
nick porter's is the batter for the
marlins
soft little looper and that one's out of
the reach of garcia so another hit for
fortes
leadoff pinch hit
for fortes and now eddie alvarez
into left field that's belt turning and
looking and that's off the wall forza is
on his way to third he's gonna get there
on the double by eddie alvarez and just
like that the marlins
have two on and nobody out here in the
seventh the big at bat from rojas he's
worked it all the way back to 3-2
payoff pitch a ground ball escobar's got
it at short
vicky brings a run home a productive out
number one
1-1 from voth
jazz lifts one left field
tagging is alvarez bell's underneath but
he makes the catch here comes eddie from
third bell's throw not in time a
sacrifice fly for jazz and the marlins
are within a run both deals to sanchez
and a line drive base hit center field
de la cruz heads toward third
ground ball up the middle and escobar
can't make the play
de la cruz is in to score sanchez goes
to third and the marlins tie it up
thomas right field
sanchez is going back that's off the
base of the wall
garcia will hold it third did not get a
good read on that one it goes all the
way to home plate
and the marlins catch a huge break the
bases are loaded payoff pitch
ground ball diaz has it he comes home
with it they get one onto first and it
gets tangled up with bell
runs coming in but they're gonna call
them out they call bell out
they call bell out for being inside the
baseline and the nationals are out to
argue obviously they would be that could
have given them the lead
but now they're saying it's too late to
challenge
and davey martinez who's still sporting
a walking boot he can't even come out
and argue
jazz goes to third throw from ruiz is
not in time
all right so the left hand first that
gets in there safely but watch the right
bare hand
with kibum losing his balance and it's
his back foot
oh
that's
painful
well the winning run is at third 2-0
count on brinson
and that one kicks away it goes to the
back stop oh my goodness
it is a wild
marlins walk-off win